تطوي ايران من صفحه عام 2022 على انتفاضه
مارس فيها النظام وكل اشكال القمع ضد
المتظاهرين من قتل وتعذيب واعتقال وحتى
اعدام منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه اعلنت
ارتفاع عدد قتلى المظاهرات المستمر في
البلاد منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر الى
476 قتيلا من بينهم اطفال
اشرت الى ان ما لا يقل عن 100 متظاهر
يواجهون حاليا خطرا الاعدام او اتهامات
تفضي الى هذه العقوبه
يوميا توثقوا في ايران مشاهد القمع والقتل
في اخرها تداول ناشطون فيديو صرخات ابنه
احد ضحايا الاحتجاجات كمال احمد بور في
مراسم مرور 40 يوما على وفاته كمال اصيب
بجروح خطيره على ايدي قوات الامن
الايرانيه وتوفي في طريقه الى المستشفى في
الثامنه عشر من نوفمبر المعطيه
النظام الايراني وفي المقابل رفع سقف
التهديد ضد المتظاهرين متوعد باشد
العقوبات هذه المره عاده الوعيد للرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم الرئيسي مؤكدا ان بلاده
لن ترحم ما وصفهم بالمعادين لايران تصريحه
جاءت امام جموع غفيره وسط ظهران خلال
مراسم تشيع رفه جنود قضوا خلال الحرب
الايرانيه العراقيه واشدد رئيسي على ان
حضن الامه الايرانيه مفتوح لكل من تم
التغرير بهم على حد وصفهم وتاهم الرئيس
الايراني وسائل اعلام بالتورط في
الاحتجاجات والترويج لمعلومات المغلوطه
فيما هدد مؤسسات الاعلاميه ناطقه
بالفارسيه في الخارج
وفي ظل الاجراءات القمعيه التي تتخذها
السلطات الايرانيه ضد المتظاهرين اظهرنا
الرياضيات ايرانيات تضامنهن مع خلع الحجاب
في محافل وطنيه واخرى عالميه
[موسيقى]